Are there things to do to prevent hair loss during chemo?
The only thing that has been shown to prevent hair loss during chemo is using cold packs on your head.
There's actually a company that makes a fitted like a helmet that you is made out of that cold pack gel stuff that you put in the freezer that you put that on your head.
By chilly your scalp, you can decrease the blood flow to the scalp and the chemo is it's flowing through your blood.
We won't damage the hair follicles because that's what happens the chemo damages the hair follicles and your hair fall sound.
Now after chemo is done usually your hair grows back in.
But if you could chill the hair follicles that you'll have less chance of your hair falling out.
But of course you don't want your hair to fall out all in certain spots so getting like those those helmets and you'd have to google the company that makes those we've had a couple people that have used those and said that they really help.
And I've seen testimonials that people have used it and it really helped so that is one option.
I would say if you're going when you're going to do chemo you do need to go back to the blog and look up the chemo protocol because you do not want to be doing strong antioxidants during the 48 hours after your chemo IV.
So let's say if you're chemo IV is at night at clock and Monday morning you'd go off of your antioxidants for 48 hours and then you'd go back on you know least 48 hours after that time after your let's say you finish the chemo IV at noon and Monday you wouldn't go back on any antioxidants until noon and Wednesday at least.
And on that chemo protocol do eat a 24 hour fast prior to the chemo is highly advised and their reason is if you think of it like a cartoon cancer cells are hungry right so they're gobbling stuff up well if you do a 24 hour fast they get super hungry.
And then you give chemo into the bloodstream they're going to eat anything and the idea is if you can think of it that way now gobble up the chemo well there has been just time and time again of people that have done that and the testimonials are they have just 50% less side effects from the chemo.
The chemo tends to work better they understand better results so do it at least a 24 hour fast prior to the chemo so if you have chemo at night at clock Monday morning we stop eating at least at night at clock Sunday morning so your cancer is super hungry and it'll gobble up the chemo and then you also go off all your antioxidants until at least 48 hours after.
The chemo is done.